welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast I'm Lindsay and I'm Greg and we
have another great show for you guys
today but first Greg do you want to tell
me
how you are what's on your mind I'm
doing well I'm doing well and what is on
my mind I've got a media recommendation
for the people out there today nice uh
you and I recently finished the show
detroiters which I think was a Comedy
Central show back in the day Comedy
Central we so I I think it was a show
that just kind of died on the vine
because Comedy Central used to have a
very stacked lineup and I think that it
was just competing against a lot of
other shows that were at the time
cultural institutions and so I I think
it just kind of never got a fair Shake
yeah but it is incredible so we we
checked it out after
um after watching I think you should
leave because we really enjoyed the
comedic stylings of Tim Robinson and so
we were interested to see like hey what
else has he done yeah we saw he had a
show called detroiters with his frequent
collaborator Sam Richardson
um which if you've watched Veep uh uh
Richard Splash yes yeah yeah he was
Richard splett from Veep if you watch
that
um but yeah so we we just decided hey we
haven't heard much about this but let's
check it out because we like these guys
and I swear to God it's one of the
funniest shows I've ever seen
it's really good so if you like
absurdist comedy or if you just watched
I think you should leave on Netflix and
thought hey what else is this Tim
Robinson guy done uh would strongly
recommend detroiters the the premise of
the show is that uh Tim Tim and Sam
while their characters at least are um
their admin from Detroit and they're
very bad at their jobs and that's about
all you need to know uh and from there
plenty of zany hijinks uh ensue the
comedy style is very similar to I think
you should leave but I think
it's not quite as unhinged I think yeah
it's not quite as unhinged and there's
also just more to sink your teeth into
because you do actually have a chance to
get to know the characters and there's a
bit of an ensemble cast
um but yeah so if if you like comedy
especially like kind of absurdist Comedy
would strongly strongly recommend
detroiters yeah and it came out before
or they started making I think you
should leave so it's also kind of fun to
see some of the roots of what would then
become
themes throughout I think you should
leave in detroiters like some of my
favorite I think you should leave
sketches are the ones that are like fake
advertisements and there are so many of
those in detroiters because that's their
job so it's just like a perfect vehicle
for just the silliest oh for sure I
think I think coffin flop is still one
of the best I think you should leave
sketches yeah yeah so what's uh what's
on your mind lens yeah I have two things
I think things I want to share today
that I'm excited about number one is
just kind of a small one but it's a huge
impact in my life I got new glasses very
nice they look they look great thank you
it's it's stupid but I have been wearing
glasses or contacts for over half my
life at this point and realize that I
have never had a pair of glasses that
actually fit me well that I've always
hated them I've always been really
annoyed by glasses and just wear
contacts
um but like had an epiphany about a
month ago that maybe that was because I
was wearing bad glasses instead of just
glasses in general being bad so I found
like this little local glasses shop here
in Raleigh that's not like attached to
an eye doctor or anything usually I just
got my glasses at the eye doctor but
it's like
a shop just for purchasing glasses and
went in there and the guy like
immediately pulled like several glasses
that were like oh this is gonna be like
perfect size for your face like fit you
perfectly and he was spot on and yeah I
have my new glasses now and they don't
slide down my nose which is this that's
been my biggest annoyance with glasses
thus far
and it's just really it's a delightful
thing to have glasses that actually fit
right so I just wanted to share that
because like if any of you have had that
have not had that Epiphany yet of like
oh maybe I'm just been wearing bad
glasses and like need to stop trying to
purchase them for my eye doctor who just
doesn't care but to sell me the most
expensive pair available they get you
the right lenses but then the frames
like yeah who cares exactly this is just
profit exactly yeah so
I think going to like a local shop and
finding somebody who like specializes in
finding a pair of glasses that fit like
your face and what you want to wear
glasses for
really makes a big difference yeah and I
also think it just illustrates a good
point which is that you know people have
a lot of negative things to say about
phrenology but
totally joking this is an
anti-frontology podcast but I like to
imagine that glasses Fitters are people
who have that skill set but use it for
good but I I didn't go to the shop with
you but I I like to imagine that he just
talks like a like a racist like 19th
century like British phrenology guy or
you'd be like from the shape of your
orbital but when I can see that you need
this particular brow Ridge like a
Louisiana guy yeah yeah I get I guess so
it's like uh Daniel Craig's character
and knives out that was the accent
you're just you're right I pulled the
complete wrong accent but I I think that
that's like a it's a similar type of guy
a Sim yeah a similar type of like racist
for knowledge yeah luckily that was not
the guy who I spoke to at the glasses
shop he was from Southern California so
about as far away from that as you can
get nice yeah
um so yeah what was what was the second
thing oh yeah so the second thing
um is I have really been loving using
the new micronutrient features in macro
factor and I know that this just like
sounds like an ad but it really is like
another thing that is just bringing me a
lot of delight at this time so I have
never tracked my micronutrient intake
before
um but since you know we had these new
features coming out in macro factor I
try to use all of the features that we
have so that I can understand the
product as well as possible and was just
kind of expecting to use the
micronutrient stuff for a couple weeks
get a hang of it and then not really
want to use it anymore because I just
historically haven't been interested in
tracking that but I've actually been
really enjoying it and it is definitely
encouraged me to add a wider variety of
like fruits and vegetables and like
whole wheat items to my diet so like
it's making me eat better but it's just
because like I like to look at the
graphs in the app and see how like
eating different things affects like how
much fiber I'm getting or saturated fat
like things like this that are important
but that I've just never really looked
at before
um so yeah like I said it sounds like an
ad but it's just like I'm really
enjoying it right now and if you like to
try track your micronutrients or just
interested or like maybe you went to the
doctor recently and you need to like
focus on eating less saturated fat which
is something that recently happened to
me then like this is helpful so if you
want to learn more about the new
micronutrient features in macro Factor
you can go to macrofactorapp.com
um we also have a bunch of new
informative articles about
micronutrients that Greg wrote recently
so that's been really helpful too for me
to like just learn more about vitamins
and minerals and like what
micronutrients actually make sense to
track because there are like 40 or 50 of
them or something so it can very quickly
get overwhelming yeah I think I think 54
yeah memory serves but the content that
you wrote Greg really helped to kind of
like narrow the focus and like really
understand what's important and what is
just kind of like well I don't really
need to pay super close attention to
that in my own diet well thank you I
certainly appreciate that
um have you have you noticed any changes
since you've started tracking your
micronutrients and trying to eat more
fruits and vegetables and stuff like are
you feeling better or different in any
way I think so like I I haven't been
sleeping as much recently that has
nothing to do with like my sleep being
affected but I just have been setting my
alarm earlier every day but my energy
levels have been about the same I think
nice and I think that that might have
something to do with just
um eating a slightly better diet and
like I think digestion has been better
and I also have had a lot of issues with
like eating too much fiber in the past
and like that causing
stomach problems or just like getting
stomach aches but I think like I ate
enough fiber or I ate like a moderate
amount of fiber for enough days in a row
that I've kind of like acclimated my
body a little bit more nice so now I do
actually feel like I can eat a wider
variety of foods without having to worry
about the tummy troubles that I was
having before sweet yeah that's that's
great to hear yeah
all right uh plugs yeah yeah let's go
through a couple quick recommendations
before we get into the meat of this
episode so if you're enjoying the show
please like rate subscribe and tell your
friends it really helps us out
um word of mouth is a huge way that
podcasts spread and all of those things
just kind of contribute to more people
learning about the podcast if you're
interested in hiring a virtual coach to
help you with your training and or
nutrition Stronger by science has a team
of excellent coaches that can help you
you can learn more at
strongerbyscience.com slash coaching
uh if you want to purchase supplements
from a reliable source and support the
podcast at the same time buy from
bulksupplements.com and use the code SBS
pod to get a five percent discount
and
um yeah I already talked about macro
factor a little bit but other than
supporting our team of coaches the main
product that Greg and I focus on these
days is macro Factor uh it's a premium
macro tracking and diet coaching app we
both use it and love it obviously from
what I've already said but 80 000 other
people use it and love it too you can
join them and try it for free for 14
days by using the code SBS during sign
up on the app store or Google Play and
if you want to learn about all the other
features of the app including all the
new micronutrient stuff you can check
out our website at macrofactorapp.com
and Greg I'm going to kick it over to
you for the rest of these plugs yeah
absolutely if if you're looking for a a
way to stay up to date with the research
coming out that is most relevant to
strength and physique athletes and
coaches check out the mass research
review that is
I think just massresearch review.com
yeah
um if you'd like to get in touch with us
uh chat about the podcast uh stay in
touch about what's going on Etc you can
join our Facebook group and subreddit
that's uh Facebook I think it's Stronger
by science community on Facebook and
reddit.com r slash stronger by science
uh if you would like free study
breakdowns send to your inbox every
other week on podcast off weeks uh you
can sign up to our newsletter where we
send our research Spotlight posts
um also just a general note if you're
listening to this and you also follow us
on Instagram the informative content we
post on Instagram is like in a bridged
version of the research Spotlight posts
so if they're if there are any of those
that you're like oh this is interesting
I'd like to know more where can I find
more uh typically the website
um just for a longer version of that and
we send those those full versions of the
those research breakdowns out in the
newsletter and finally if you have
questions for the podcast that you'd
like us to address record a brief audio
file UH 60 seconds or less and email it
to podcast at strongerbuyscience.com and
if we like it we will address it on the
show and by the way that's another good
reason to join the Facebook group and
subreddit because when we have a
particular topic for an episode that
we're going to cover I'll post about it
in the Facebook group and subreddit to
solicit questions particularly for that
subject I did that this time around and
so yeah if you'd like to increase the
probability that you ask a question that
we answer on the podcast the the
Facebook group and subreddit are a good
way to know what topics we're going to
be covering on the podcast and therefore
what sorts of questions were we're
generally looking for
yeah and you mentioned that we
our questions this week about the topic
the topic is pre-sleep nutrition
so I wanted to talk about this after I I
saw an article recently from The
Washington Post about a new cereal that
post-consumer brands has started selling
the article is a couple months old at
this point but I haven't heard much
about this subject
um so I thought it'd be interesting to
talk about here so the cereal is called
sweet dreams and it's marketed as a
pre-bed snack with quote curated
ingredients for healthy nighttime habits
and quote part of a healthy sleep
routine so basically they're selling
this cereal telling you that it's going
to help you sleep better so some of the
claims that they make about it on the
website page is that it's the first
ready to eat cereal specially designed
to support a good sleep routine and a
fresh start to the next day and it's
made with delicious and wholesome
ingredients a nighttime herbal blend of
lavender and chamomile and curated
vitamins and minerals like zinc acid and
B vitamins to support natural melatonin
production
there are two flavors blueberry midnight
containing blueberry lavender and
chamomile which honestly sounds gross to
me
yeah yeah I don't I don't know hmm so I
I mean here here's my thing yeah
um like we'll we'll talk about this a
little bit more but there there is some
evidence suggesting that lavender might
help with sleep or at least relaxation
but also it's a kind of strong flavor
yeah and I do think that lavender or
just like floral stuff in general can
pair well with berry flavors but also
I'm skeptical that you'd be able to get
enough lavender for it to actually have
the desired effect without without it
just tasting like an air freshener yeah
and like the artificial lavender taste
is way different than like if you've had
lavender from like a lavender extract
um in the artificial lavender it really
just tastes like soap
yeah yeah that is that is unfortunately
the case with a lot of
a lot of extracts because because like
one
um not all of the volatile compounds in
whatever you're dealing with will be
soluble in the same uh like solution so
you know some things are will dissolve
well in alcohol some will dissolve well
in oil some will dissolve well in water
or whatever like it's hard to get the
full round flavor of something with a
single extract
um
and also a lot of those volatile
compounds are volatile like they'll
they'll kind of just percolate away
which is which is why like things with
strong sense like a perfume or whatever
if you leave it open it the smell gets
less and less intense over time because
it's volatile like that's what it means
and that that's how you can smell it in
the first place like these compounds are
volatile they they go out of solution
and up into the air so they can make it
to your nose and you can smell them
um but yeah so I I think that there
would be a lot of challenges to get kind
of the full round flavor of lavender in
a shelf stable product because a lot of
those compounds and aromatics
probably wouldn't necessarily want to
stick around so you probably have to do
some sort of like witchcraft to take
like a small subset of those scent
compounds or flavor compounds or
whatever that give you like some of the
feeling of lavender uh that you can make
stable enough to to put in cereal in a
box and it'd still be there when someone
eats it but yeah it's it's the same way
with vanilla for what it's worth like if
you've I I realize that I've already
gone off on a tangent I apologize but uh
recommendation for for uh cooking heads
out there cooking head cooking heads
yeah is that what you call yourselves in
that Community I don't know home home
Cooks I guess okay
gourmands gourmands it whatever but
um but yeah so if you've never had fresh
vanilla beans before one you probably
don't want to get into a huge habit of
using them because they're expensive
they're pretty expensive
um but if you've never had fresh vanilla
before I would recommend getting some
just fresh vanilla beans at some point
because the there there is so much more
going on in vanilla beans than vanilla
extract
um because mostly there you're just
isolating the vanillin which is the main
compound that gives vanilla its
characteristic flavor but there's so
much more going on in the individual
Bean
um
so it's very nice like it's it's an
experience worth having I think okay I'm
sorry that's okay you know actually
that's a decent segue because the other
flavor of this cereal contains vanilla
oh nice it's honeymoon glow containing
honey vanilla lavender and chamomile
so those are the two flavors of this new
cereal that post-consumer Brands is
trying to sell as like a sleep cereal
um and I I love this quote from the
press release Greg will you will you
read this quote yes
more than ever consumers are looking to
embrace acts of self-care particularly
as it relates to bedtime routines and we
believe a relaxing bedtime routine is
key to a good night's sleep as a brand
that's been helping early risers Crush
their morning routines for over a
hundred years we're thrilled to now help
fans also establish healthy nighttime
Habits by providing a nutrient dense
before bed snack made to support a sleep
routine that they could only dream of
until now
that's extra as hell damn they are so
high on their own they really are so
obviously we're not going to talk about
this cereal the entire episode but I
just thought this was an interesting
entry point to talking about how
marketing creates new food routines and
claims regarding supplements and
nutrients that allegedly help us get
better sleep and then we're gonna turn
to Greg to tell us what the science
actually says about nutrition and sleep
so there are a couple interesting and
amusing marketing tactics being used for
this cereal that I just wanted to note
um first is the way that the sales copy
informs the consumer about nighttime
rituals and it like weaves in
consumption of their product as a
healthy way to end the day so on the
back of the box of cereal there's a
five-step bedtime routine that starts
with eating the cereal so the first step
is relax with a bowl of sweet dream
cereal number two keep a set bedtime for
regularity number three switch off
devices an hour before Sleep Number Four
save 30 minutes for winding down and
number five try meditation or breathing
techniques
damn it's crazy it's almost like you
could shorten that to a four-step
bedtime routine it does seem like that
but
you gotta start the routine with eating
the cereal Greg sure yeah so
it's really smart that they did this
the tips other than eating a bowl of
cereal obviously are likely to help
people get better sleep like those are
very normal things to recommend to
somebody who is trying to sleep better
so the chance of somebody
attributing their better sleep to the
product is much higher yeah and when I
told you about this earlier you brought
up another example of like a company
that did this oh yeah yeah so for people
around our age to maybe slightly younger
uh there was a a program called P90X
that was advertised heavily online and
infomercials all over the place for uh
probably five or six years or so
um and it promised that it would help
you get in better shape get
shredded Etc the the claims that you
expect from all kind of quick fix uh
Fitness things yeah
um but the the very smart thing about it
is they made all of these claims about
their workouts like they're they're the
ones who uh
I wouldn't say completely popularized
but like finished I would say the
popularization of the idea of epoch like
the idea that if you do high intensity
workouts you'll keep burning way more
calories when the workout is over
um so it's like hey these are these are
short workouts but you really get after
it and then guess what you you keep
burning hundreds and hundreds of more
calories for the next day to three wow
whatever that'd be convenient it would
be and the thing is like that is a real
effect but it the magnitude of it is
relatively trivial of course um but yeah
like that that's what they attributed
the purported results to but if you
bought P90X it also came with a diet
that it strongly recommended you follow
which was basically a crash diet yeah
and so like yeah a lot of people used
P90x and lost a bunch of weight and said
ah man this these high intensity
workouts in the epoch it's magic
and it's like dude you're you're like
you started at 2 30 and you're eating a
thousand calories a day like you really
you really think the workouts are are
what did this for you yeah but yeah it
sounds similar with this cereal where it
says hey do all of the good things we
know uh related to sleep hygiene and
also eat our cereal and then if you
start sleeping better guess what our
cereal it's an integral part of the
process absolutely yeah
um something else is if you can get
people to establish a new Pleasant
routine based entirely around consuming
your product you're more likely to gain
a repeat customer so if somebody comes
to associate bedtime with eating a bowl
of cereal that's going to be a huge win
for the brand and obviously like that's
a pleasant thing to do like most people
like eating cereal so it's like if you
can if your brain starts associating
like oh it's time to wind down and I get
to have my nightly Bowl cereal that I
enjoy then you know you're going to keep
buying that cereal and we see this with
other items I I think it's kind of like
associating watching a movie in the
movie theater with getting popcorn and a
soda like you sit down
um or you walk in and that Association
is already there it's like part of the
routine so you're going to do it every
time and you're going to be a repeat
customer or like associating attending a
sports game with like eating a hot dog
and getting a beer
I mean I I would even toss like a
Thanksgiving turkey in there yeah I
don't think anyone loves turkey I don't
think it's anyone's like favorite food
you always say you love turkey every
Thanksgiving and that you're gonna make
turkey more often and then you never do
well okay here's the thing here's the
problem with turkey okay
um
so one
I cook a mean turkey most people don't
like most most birds you get are going
to be very dry yeah uh and we've we've
talked about how to cook a good turkey
on the podcast before I don't remember
what episode guess what just listen to
the entire back catalog just go back in
the November ones like it's gonna be
around that time yeah I think American
Thanksgiving I think it was no a
November episode of our very first year
um but yeah I may as well just listen to
all of the old episodes of course yeah
just in case um
but yeah so I I cook a pretty good bird
you do you cook a very good turkey most
Thanksgiving turkeys suck yes
um and turkeys much like chickens are
way too like breast heavy in terms of
the total amount of meat yeah and turkey
breast Is Not Great meat but turkey
thigh is delicious so if I could find a
hookup around here to just buy bone-in
skin on turkey thighs
I would I would be in business like that
that is that is something I would be
extremely interested in but like when
you cook a Thanksgiving turkey 80 of the
meat you get off of it is just going to
be breast meat
um which is not great but people
associate it so strongly with the
holiday yeah that
if that Association were ever broken
like I think turkey Farmers would just
be that's true you know yeah yeah
so there are so like they they know that
so many people are gonna buy turkeys
every year so if that ever stopped it
would be a disaster I also think that
association should kind of be broken
though like yeah here's the thing if
you're listening and you're the person
who hosts Thanksgiving for your family
um just you know figure out who's gonna
be there for this coming Thanksgiving
and maybe send out a poll and say send
out a poll and yeah and say hey like if
we're going to have a big hunk of meat
as the centerpiece for this Feast what
do people like yeah and I you know some
people traditionalists some might say
turkey but I think I think there's going
to be a lot of people saying ah what if
we did ribs or like what if we did a big
beef roast yeah or a big rib roast yeah
that would be amazing or if you want to
stay in the uh
if you want to stay in the foul family
of course uh you could take a page out
of the book of our friends across the
pond and go with goose oh yeah goose is
awesome we did a Christmas goose a
couple years ago this is delicious yeah
yeah
um anyway yeah let's let's get back to
bed yeah people yes people associate
turkey with Thanksgiving absolutely
that's true that is the only point I was
trying to make
uh the last
um the last little thing I think is
smart about their five-step bedtime
routine that starts with eating the bowl
of cereal is that they're creating a new
Meal Time entirely specifically to slot
their product into so they're not
there's not as much competition at this
time so instead of like telling people
to eat cereal for breakfast they're
saying like oh actually we're creating
this new time of day that you're going
to eat and guess what our product is the
perfect thing to slot in there and
that's similar to like Taco Bell doing
their fourth meal thing it's exactly the
same it's just cereal as a fourth meal
yeah
yeah I I agree although I don't really
even know if that was the point of Taco
Bell's marketing I think it was more
just like Hey look
who would you eat when you're face
they know yeah and we just want to make
sure you're aware when you're driving
home from the bar one don't tell us how
much you drank while you're sitting in
the Taco Bell drive-through line that's
none of our business but two that's
where you should come because guess what
we are still open so
yeah yeah yeah
I I enjoy a Taco Bell Fourth meal though
I think that's that's a good marketing
campaign I agree
even late yeah uh
so the second thing that I'll say about
just the marketing in general the
obviousness of why they are doing this
right now serial sales have been down
um they went up during the pandemic
um along with other packaged foods made
to eat at home makes sense but since
then inflation and folks returning to
society has resulted in a decline in the
Cold Cereal sales and it's been part of
a larger trend of more people skipping
breakfast entirely or eating Foods on
the go so like going through the
drive-through and getting breakfast at
like McDonald's
or just opting for other types of
breakfast foods that they perceive as
healthier than cereal so foods that are
higher in protein or lower in Sugar yeah
I mean that that's a that's a pretty
wide net to cast like food's healthier
than most breakfast series
this is just an aside and we're not
going to get into it at all but I I read
like a little bit about the history of
cereal whenever I was doing uh the
research for this episode and whenever
people first started selling cereal it
was branded as like the perfect health
food yeah
no I I'm I'm aware but it's obviously
not it
it also had a lot less sugar
that's true that's true that's before
they started making candy cereal yeah
and I also think that they may have had
a slightly different operational
definition of Health uh to Encompass the
idea of you'll be you'll be healthy
because you'll be retaining more of your
vital Essences because you're going to
eat this product and never bust again
like that was yeah the John Harvey
Kellogg stuff yeah
somebody you guys need to go back and
listen to our vibration plate episode if
you want more John Harvey Kellogg
content because out of context that just
sounded insane Greg breakfast cereal was
made by the uh were they Quakers or
Seventh-Day Adventists yeah yeah they
were Adventists anyway they thought that
all like what it's not worth getting
into but they they thought that getting
horny was bad and if you ate cereal or
also like graham crackers which also
didn't used to be sweetened
um they they made those as foods that
you could eat to live a a pure life free
from sin and Temptation and that would
make you healthier because you would be
retaining your vital Essences
um anyway not not probably the best
ideas that are completely in line with
modern science yeah uh but yeah they
like I don't doubt that old cereals did
actually used to be a lot healthier
because essentially it's just a whole
grain product yeah it's not sweetened
and is easily consumable like there's
nothing wrong with that except for the
taste and so then they just threw a
bunch of sugar on it they're like what
if we add marshmallows right
and now they have oops all marshmallows
that's
maybe maybe they got rid of that but
yeah that was
I think that was the point when
breakfast cereal just fully jumped the
shark yeah yeah they had the Lucky
Charms oops all marshmallows
I mean just come like even if you ever
want marshmallows with milk for
breakfast yeah like the Cookie Crisp is
one thing it's just like we're going to
make a Pop-Tart cereal too now yeah but
when it gets to the point that you're
like yes I'm just going to pour a bowl
of marshmallows and pour milk over it
like that's you've you've gone to it's
truly cursed yeah it's it's time for the
pendulum to swing back at that point
right so for that reason and the others
that I listed already cereal cells have
been down
but
marketing for sleep aids is booming so
sales of foods beverages supplements and
other products that help people sleep
totaled 74.3 billion dollars in 2021
according to precedence research and
that's expected to increase to nearly
125 billion dollars by 2030.
um and that's from a article in Business
Insider so
post-consumer cereal wants to sell more
cereal but they know that fewer people
are eating cereal at breakfast
but they see that market trends are
towards sleep aid products
so we get sweet dream cereal that's
smart I mean I can't knock the hustle
yeah it really is
um so I think it's just
it's such a perfect case study of like
marketing kind of driving a product
rather than they're actually being any
intention of creating a product
specifically for consumers to enjoy
maybe they really care about improving
your sleep but maybe they care more
about their bottom line and taking
advantage of what they see as a market
opportunity
yeah yeah I mean both could be true but
I think one might be more true than the
other yeah so I think it's just it's
important to say just be cognizant that
this is a hot market right now and there
are going to be a lot of people and
businesses trying to sell you that
you don't need and that's not going to
work yeah and I think that's a good
segue to announce that we're launching
our own line of sleep supplements
they're called Stronger by science sweet
dreams
you just took the name of this cereal it
has to be something else they're called
Sleepy by science
um
and uh yeah no that's a joke sleepier by
science that is there's an idea but no
we're not doing that I do want to talk
about some other products in the
pre-event market though because I do
think it's just kind of fun and silly
so
I found this whole company dedicated to
nighttime snacks called night food
um their website says that quote Sleep
Experts formulated night food for
guilt-free nighttime snacking with a
sleep-friendly nutritional profile
they sell cookies and ice cream hell
yeah
and of course they can say things like
our ice cream contains more tryptophan
calcium magnesium and zinc than
traditional ice cream because they're
adding those they're adding those things
in and it's like nobody's nobody's
looking at their ice cream and being
like well how much tryptophan is in here
yeah
um so for the ice cream the macros look
pretty similar to Halo top which markets
itself as a more macro Friendly Ice
Cream and that's a pretty it's a pretty
controversial product so we won't get
into that
um but the night food ice cream doesn't
have erythritol is that how you say that
yeah yeah the sugar alcohol and I think
that's the thing that that really
a lot of people up about Halo top is the
sugar alcohol yeah yeah sugar alcohol is
one of those or various sugar alcohols
uh are are things where they they taste
nicer than I think most other low or
non-neutral like low calorie or
non-nutrient sweeteners in small doses
um but but yeah if you eat a lot of them
it might become a problem I I forget
which there there is kind of like a a
ranking of which ones cause the most
tummy troubles yeah I think uh if memory
serves I think Sorbitol is the one that
a lot of people have issues with
erythritol is kind of in the middle I
think Xylitol people can often eat quite
a bit of and be fine it could be a
completely different order so don't
don't take that too seriously but yeah
like it in if if people listening and I
know I've recommended this on the
podcast before but I will every time
sugar alcohols come up
just Google sugar-free gummy bears
Amazon review there is a there there is
a piece of found art on the internet
about this topic that that warns against
the dangers of excess sugar alcohol
consumption and you owe it to yourself
to check it out yeah yeah if you're not
sure how your body reacts to sugar
alcohol maybe make sure you're at home
when you eat it
yeah yeah yeah so so anyways this this
night food ice cream doesn't have the
sugar alcohol
um and just to compare to other ice
creams it seems like they just added
tryptophan calcium some magnesium some
zinc and some vitamin B6 and it's like
eight dollars per pint which is pretty
steep yeah
for the cookies
so they sell the ice cream and cookies
the macros aren't very different from
like Chips Ahoy Oreos like it's just a
straight up Cookie
um the main difference is that they have
more protein like it's four grams of
protein per serving Chips Ahoy and Oreos
have one gram but it's like you're not
eating cookies for for four grams of
protein anyways and the sugar difference
is six grams versus 10 grams so
I don't know that doesn't seem like a
huge difference to me and the calorie
difference is 120 versus 140. so I mean
at that like you're just eating Chips
Ahoy at that point yeah
um and then it just seems like there's
some added vitamin B6 and inocidal is
that how you say that I think it's
inositol okay whatever that is
uh and the cookies are 14.99 for a three
bag pack each bag seems like it contains
about 12 little cookies so that seems
like it's also steep yeah maybe a little
better than the ice cream but pretty
steep and those cookies I don't know I
feel like there's no way pre-made
cookies taste like yeah it's
there's no way except for and if if you
if you don't love yourself at all uh
grandma's cookies Grandma's brand
cookies
um man they I I am against the concept
of guilty pleasure in the abstract like
I don't think people should feel guilty
about their pleasure as long as it's not
hurting anyone but I would consider
grandma's cookies a guilty pleasure of
mine
um because my God they are so good and
they make me feel like complete dog
after I eat them every time so that's
the guilt yeah yeah I get I guess it's
more like regret than guilt yeah it's a
regretful pleasure yeah yeah
yeah so um anyway but those are pre-made
cookies that for my money they're
they're good the rest of them not good
correct yeah
um so that's that night food company and
then I want to talk about one other
company
um it's called the functional chocolate
company and they have a product called
Sleepy chocolate
the company's whole schtick seems to be
chocolate with added vitamins and
minerals that claim to help with
specific health issues so sleepy
chocolate is just one of their offerings
um they also have
pain-free chocolate formulated for
everyday aches and pains Carefree
chocolate formulated to help you
stabilize stress and now we get into the
funny ones sexy chocolate formulated to
help launch your libido in a rhythm
chocolate formulated to help you pause
your PMS I don't know what pausing your
PMS means I feel like I don't want to
pause it I just want to get on through
it like yeah skip it yeah you're just
saving it up and then there's a
chocolate shortage and you can't get
your Rhythm you've been eating this for
like three years straight and uh you're
you're you've just been uh you've been
pausing your PMS yeah for you know three
quarters of an Olympiad and then you
can't get your hands on the Rhythm
chocolate anymore and then you're
God help everyone in your immediate
vicinity
um and they also have one that's
supposed to help you manage menopause
that's called hot chocolate I feel like
that's a bad name
I think there's another product called
hot chocolate already is there I think I
believe so
[Laughter]
yeah I feel like they they did the
little pun there like hot flashes but
it is just like you just think of the
beverage yeah
so the Sleepy chocolate contains
chamomile Valerian lavender lemon balm
magnesium and melatonin but there's
nothing on their website anywhere that
says how much of any of those are
actually in a serving and they cost 7.89
per chocolate bar which is pretty
impressive
yeah that's that's pretty steep and ah
man I forget what it's called but I
believe there's a there's a compound in
chocolate that behaves a lot like
caffeine like it's yeah from the same
family I think it I think it might be
called Throw romb Bean or something
um but yeah like chocolate itself has
like mild stimulatory properties yeah I
had forgotten about that but yeah so
like I
I don't know like maybe it'll be housed
in a chocolate bar right before bed yeah
I I mean I'm sure that it's not enough
to like really up your sleep but I
also feel like for a sleep supplement
there is probably a better vehicle to be
had than a chocolate bar yeah it might
just be like I'm I'm sure it's just
because chocolate is a pretty good
cover-up of other flavors and so they
can kind of like
squeeze a bunch of other in there
without it tasting too disgusting yeah
yeah that would make sense
all right
so those are those are the other couple
um products that are kind of trying to
cash in on this big sleep aid
market right now
um so I want to move now into talking
about the claims regarding the
supplements and nutrients that allegedly
help us get better sleep that that are
in these products
um for the sweet dreams cereal
specifically they say that the lavender
chamomile and vitamins and minerals in
the cereal which were zinc folic acid
and B vitamins support natural melatonin
production
and for the vitamins and minerals like
sure I don't know maybe I think that's
probably true that those things can
support melatonin production but we'll
talk about that more in a minute
um I looked at examine.com sleep
supplement guide to learn more about
sleep supplements just as kind of the
background for this but I know Greg you
have some specific stuff to talk about
for each one but I was actually a little
surprised to learn that
um examine says there aren't any
supplements that we know of that have a
considerable benefit a high degree of
evidence in our broadly applicable for
supporting sleep
there are a few secondary and promising
supplements in their guide those are
like the other categories that are
classified that way because they either
lack robust evidence or are more likely
to have modest effects on average
Lavender is one of the ones that is
listed as a secondary supplement and
that's one of the items obviously
mentioned in the sweet dreams cereal
marketing the other supplement in that
category on the examine guide is
melatonin and all others on the page are
in the lower tiers of promising or
unproven
um
yeah I know that that is true yeah do
you want me to talk about lavender now
I'll just say like
what I what I um gleaned from the
examine page is that most lavender
research has been done using inhaled oil
yeah so
it's it seems promising but it's kind of
weird to compare like ingesting lavender
versus the aromatherapy of lavender and
studies on oral supplementation are much
more recent most of them use a
proprietary lavender extract called
selection which is dosed at 80
milligrams which is probably a lot more
lavender than you're getting from that
cereal
um and the sweet dream cereal doesn't
share how much lavender is used we
probably cannot assume that it's enough
to make an effective dose yeah I I
probably wouldn't make that assumption
um but yeah so just to talk a little bit
more about lavender
um
like you mentioned most of the research
to this point has used lavender
inhalation uh testing its effects on
various things
um which has led to a misconception that
I've encountered a couple times around
the web which is that lavender doesn't
actually like mechanistically do
anything
um so there there's a supposition I
sometimes see that lavender only exerts
its effects just due to associations
people have built up with it like at
some point people decided Lavender is
relaxing so we're going to make lavender
scented creams and oils and stuff
um and and aromatherapy and whatnot and
so you're trying to relax you smell
lavender when you're trying to relax and
so you just come to associate lavender
with relaxation but lavender itself
doesn't actually do anything
therefore ingested lavender wouldn't do
anything like it would just be the smell
of lavender that would have effects yeah
and that doesn't seem to be completely
true through so there is uh like in
vitro petri dish research on the the
bioactive compounds present in lavender
um finding that they have effects on the
nmda receptor and the serotonin
transporter and most like psychological
effects they would have would probably
be Downstream of those effects
um there has been a a meta-analysis of
human studies on lavender finding that
lavender usage seems to have a small but
statistically significant effect on
measures of Stress and Anxiety
um there was also a systematic review
published a couple years ago
um so just a just a systematic review
not meta-analysis the the studies had
too much heterogeneity to bother like
pooling and statistically analyzing but
most of the studies that have looked at
the effects of lavender on sleep have
broadly positive results
um so it like examine.com said it is
promising
um but I think due to its mechanistic
effects
um it's probably if it does help sleep
it probably does so primarily by having
effects on Stress and Anxiety
um it could be General Stress and
Anxiety or maybe just anxiety about
falling asleep if you're if you're a
poor sleeper you know it's it's hard to
sleep if you're too stressed out
um and so yeah if you are
if you are stressed or you have specific
Stress and Anxiety about sleep lavender
might be able to help you out because
that it it doesn't seem to like increase
melatonin production or affect like Gaba
signaling which is a big thing in sleep
as well like the the nmda and serotonin
related stuff like that would be mostly
related to Stress and Anxiety rather
than sleep directly
um but yeah like it it does seem to have
like actual mechanistic effects it's not
all just about associations that people
have with the scent of lavender so I I
could see ways where ingested lavender
could potentially influence sleep
secondary to maybe slightly decreasing
Stress and Anxiety a little bit
um but yeah I wouldn't expect a
particularly large effect for anyone
yeah and in particular people who aren't
stressed out or stressed about sleep
like I for those folks I doubt lavender
would do much if anything
one of the other things mentioned as an
ingredient that I kind of pair with
lavender in my mind is chamomile uh what
do you know about chamomile yeah so
chamomile
does seem to more directly influence
sleep or at least like biochemical
Pathways associated with sleep
um so also just as a general note
um as is always the case the the
research that I reference here will all
be linked in the show notes if you want
to check it out
um but yeah there was a there was a 2019
uh just kind of like
broad meta-analysis on the effects of
chamomile on various things including
State anxiety generalized anxiety
disorder insomnia and Sleep Quality
um and it found that
um
chamomile did seem to not have much of
an effect on uh like State anxiety but
it might help a little bit with
generalized anxiety disorder and might
improve Sleep Quality a bit
I'll also link a cool paper that talks
about the mechanisms by which chamomile
exerts its effects there are a lot of
bioactive compounds in chamomile but the
most important one here seems to be one
called apogenin which is a flavonoid and
uh apogenin itself seems to have like
Direct effects on relevant biochemical
Pathways associated with sleep so it
interacts with the benzodiazepine
receptors in the brain and generally
enhances Gaba signaling and that Gaba is
a generally inhibitory neurotransmitter
like it it does different things in
different parts of the brain but
generally it just kind of it's like a
dimmer switch it kind of like tones
things down a little bit makes it a
little bit easier to relax nice
um so yeah like chamomile I I would like
to see
more direct human research on the
effects of chamomile on sleep especially
in people who aren't insomniacs or don't
have some other type of sleep disorder
like they're there there are a lot of
time supplements or products or whatever
that can have positive effects in people
who have you know some sort of like
quantifiable problem yeah but if you're
a normal sleeper or a good sleeper
they're not really going to do anything
for you so I would like to see more
research on chamomile in that context
and people who do already sleep pretty
well and just want to sleep a little bit
better
um but yeah there's there's some some
decent human evidence that it might
improve Sleep Quality
um and mechanistic evidence that it does
actually interact with neurochemical
Pathways that are directly relevant for
sleep so I think it's pretty promising
um but as was the case with lavender as
well I'm somewhat skeptical that there
would be enough chamomile in these
products to actually do much so most of
the human evidence like most of the
human studies that have tested the
effects of chamomile on sleep use a
dosage of between 400 milligrams and 2
grams of chamomile extract per day which
is which is kind of a lot like I
I think that if you had that much
chamomile in a bowl of cereal it would
just oh it taste overwhelmingly of
chamomile and like same would apply to
Chocolate as well yeah also just really
quick
um that's all I had to say about
chamomile but I wanted to to fact check
myself real quick okay the compound in
chocolate that behaves a lot like
caffeine is called theobromine okay uh
yeah I I realized I had seen that word a
lot but had never said it out loud and
how I thought it would be pronounced is
is not the phonetically correct way
um so yes theobromine not throw rambine
no idea where that came from that's okay
but yeah okay
um
so chamomile lavender
the things that they mentioned were
um zinc folic acid and B vitamins and
the marketing claimed that those things
support natural
melatonin production
uh Greg what do you think about that is
that how it works
um
you know I I could see that
simultaneously being a statement that's
true but also not super relevant for
most people
um
so yeah I
I looked around a little bit for this
I'm sure it's in a textbook somewhere
that I couldn't find but I was trying to
find
um
like detailed information on the like
biochemistry of melatonin like it really
really nitty-gritty stuff about
melatonin synthesis because essentially
you start with tryptophan you go through
a few steps eventually you wind up with
melatonin
um and most of the stuff I found was
just kind of going through how the
tryptophan originally tryptophan
molecule changes with each reaction but
it didn't necessarily go through what
enzymes catalyze it and what cofactors
and coenzymes like affect those
enzymatic reactions and I wouldn't be at
all surprised if zinc folic acid B
vitamins magnesiums one that's thrown in
here as well sometimes I I do not know
if this is the case but I would not be
surprised at all if those vitamins and
minerals were like coenzymes and
cofactors for some of those chemical
reactions like that wouldn't shock me at
all
but even if that so if that is the case
the claim that those things support
natural melatonin production would be
completely true but if your intake or
like serum levels uh of those
vitamins and minerals were sufficient in
the first place yeah taking in more
probably won't further increase
melatonin production and those also
aren't vitamins and minerals with really
high rates of insufficient intake yeah
um so I I I think I think that the claim
that
that it supports natural melatonin
production is both true and misleading
yeah and
mentioned the insufficient intake I I
did pay some stuff in here specifically
from your micronutrient articles that
you recently published um but we'll just
go through each of these so for zinc the
likelihood of insufficient intake is low
most people in developed countries
consume adequate amounts same with folic
acid same with vitamin B6 vitamin B12
the likelihood of insufficient intake is
moderate most adults generally consume
adequate amounts of B12 but the
likelihood of insufficient intake in low
blood B12 levels is considerably higher
for vegans and elderly people
but there's there's a lot better sources
of vitamin B12 than just getting it in
some random cereal you could get it from
shellfish liver fatty fish beef and
dairy products and then
most vegans will need to use B12
supplements in order to achieve an
adequate intake because plants don't
synthesize vitamin B12 though algae and
seaweed like Nori like seaweed snacks
dried seaweed can be a good vegan source
of B12 yeah B12 is an interesting little
thing it's um
it's necessary for most life but also
really the only things that synthesize
B12 are certain bacteria and also
certain algae and that's it yeah and
that's wild yeah so all of the B12 that
you
consume comes from one of those sources
I don't know like maybe for for
supplements like maybe they they like
biosynthesize it in in a lab now that
wouldn't surprise me but from from
natural food sources yeah like like
algae makes B12 in the ocean and then uh
yeah the the shellfish and whatnot that
have high levels of B12 it's all just
from things eating algae and kind of
accruing that B12 which you then get
um and for like animal like things not
in the ocean that have B12
um a lot of it comes from ruminants
where they have bacteria in their
stomach that help them digest stuff and
some of those bacteria produce B12 which
the ruminant then absorbs and then it
has B12 in its flesh and milk
um so yeah that's where that's where
like all of the natural B12 comes from
and so so if you're a vegan and don't
consume animal products really the the
way to go is kind of that algae route so
uh like you mentioned seaweed like Nori
is a pretty good source of B12 which
which is an algae
um but also they make vegan B12
supplements in the form of of algae oil
which is also a good uh a good source of
um EPA and DHA as well nice
but yeah so
that's
that's about all I have to say about
that in terms of of like intake and
sources yeah did you want to talk any
about zinc
yeah so I I do have a couple more things
to say about zinc and b12 Beyond just
the general marketing claim of support
natural melatonin production so there
there is some stuff suggesting that zinc
and b12 might have independent effects
on sleep independent and apart from
supporting melatonin production
and in the case of zinc it's it's one of
those things that's kind of speculative
like it's it's a bit of a where there's
smoke there might be fire type of
situation
um so I'll link a review uh in the show
notes as well called dietary zinc acts
as a sleep modulator which I think might
be slightly too strong of a claim for
the title of that paper but essentially
what the research suggests with zinc is
one just on a pure associations level
people who sleep less tend to have lower
blood concentrations of zinc which could
suggest that not sleeping enough
depletes zinc levels in the blood or it
could suggest that people who don't eat
enough zinc don't sleep enough or it
could suggest that uh behaviors that
that something else is simultaneously
influencing the concentrations and sleep
but those two things aren't like you
know it's associations so do with it
yeah but like those are associations
have been observed like people who don't
sleep as much do have lower blood levels
of zinc
um there is surprisingly little direct
human research on zinc supplementation
and its effects on sleep but the stuff
that does exist
is is positive but inconclusive yeah so
there have been uh two studies
um looking at zinc supplementation in
malnourished infants with pretty
promising uh findings
there was one study on insomniacs that
found up like really large effect on
Sleep Quality but interesting the the
catch there is that it was combined
supplementation with zinc magnesium and
melatonin so it's it's hard to know yeah
the extent to which those findings are
attributable to zinc
um and then there was one study from
Japan on healthy adults that that slept
pretty well
um that found positive effects on sleep
onset latency and sleep efficiency but
the supplementation in the study wasn't
just zinc straight up they increased
zinc intake via consumption of oysters
which are very high in zinc and zinc
Rich yeast extracts
um I love to have a plate of oysters in
bed uh I don't uh but I don't either I
do not eat food in bed that's girls uh
yeah so so yeah it's one of those things
where it found positive effects when
consuming zinc rich foods but that's
interesting there are other things in
oysters and yeast extracts than zinc so
it very true be attributable to
something else
um there's also some
interesting but kind of weird uh rodent
research so uh just as background mice
sleep mice generally sleep more during
the day and less at night but they also
just kind of nap throughout the day they
don't really have the same sleep
patterns and sleep architecture that we
do but they they average about 20
minutes per hour of sleep at night and
about 40 minutes of sleep per hour
during the day
um and so some rodent research found
that Zinc at night which is generally
when they're when rodents are more
active uh decreased locomotor activity
and increased non-rem sleep
um so that's that's making them sleepier
when they would generally be more active
um but they they didn't find that effect
uh during the day when they would
otherwise be sleepy so it's it's hard to
know exactly what to do without yeah
except it does suggest that the zinc
itself did have some effect on something
related to sleep to make these rats
sleep a little bit more yeah or or mice
I mean
um and they did also uh test other
um
other like metallic cations similar to
zinc to see if to see if this was a
generalized thing or a zinc specific
thing so they also tested manganese iron
and copper and they didn't observe
similar effects with those other like
metallic ions suggesting that it might
be something like specific to zinc so
anyway it's you know it's hard to know
exactly what to do with that because you
know also we aren't mice and our sleep
the way we sleep is pretty different to
how I sleep but it does again suggest
that zinc is directly doing something
potentially related to sleep uh and and
the folks that wrote this paper
um
suggested that it might have something
to do with the concentration of zinc
ions in cerebrospinal fluid and that
that might directly influence sleep
somehow
um essential so there's precedence for
that to some extent because previous
also rodent research has looked at the
impact associations and impact of
different ion concentrations in cerebral
spinal fluid on sleep so looking at mice
that are awake versus asleep and looking
at concentrations of potassium calcium
and magnesium levels in their
cerebrospinal fluid and they found that
when they were awake they saw higher
levels of potassium lower levels of
calcium and magnesium when they were
asleep lower levels of potassium higher
levels of calcium and magnesium which
could just be a mere Association it or
it might just be reflecting like
metabolic changes within the brain and
spinal Accord but it's not actually
doing anything causal yeah but then they
experimentally said Hey what if we what
if we took the the ion concentration
seen when mice are asleep and injected
that into their cerebrospinal fluid when
they were awake so you know we're just
experimentally changing the ion
Solutions in their ER concentrations in
their cerebrospinal fluid will that
influence sleeper behavior and it did so
if you took like low level potassium
high level calcium and magnesium like
cerebrospinal fluid and injected that
into mice that were awake they moved
around less slept more so that that
again suggests some sort of causal
relationship so the the folks that wrote
uh that wrote this article about zinc
suggested that maybe something similar
with zinc is going on but they're
they're at least of the time that this
article was published wasn't direct
research to confirm that yeah
um so anyway we don't
mechanistically know why zinc influences
sleep but there is some circle some
circumstantial evidence to suggest that
it does and in more of a direct way than
just influencing melatonin production
interesting
um
with vitamin B12 as well there's some
evidence uh related to vitamin B12 and
sleep again suggesting that it might be
doing something apart from like just
being a cofactor for melatonin
production or whatever
so there's a line of research suggesting
that vitamin B12 might modulate uh
circadian rhythm by increasing the light
sensitivity of the circadian clock like
in in your brain
um and I'm not going to get into this
research in depth but basically it might
help make you sleepy a little bit
earlier especially if your circadian
rhythm has gotten up
um so you know if you're if ideally you
might want your melatonin levels to be
increasing it uh like seven o'clock at
night or whatever yeah they're high
enough at 10 to go to sleep at 10 if you
want to go to sleep at 10 but your
circadian rhythm like your your
melatonin levels are peaking at midnight
or whatever like later than you actually
want your bedtime to be there's some
evidence suggesting that
uh vitamin B12 might help with that a
little bit by phase shifting your your
melatonin ramp up a little bit earlier
in the day
um so that's
like there's something there but like
it's kind of speculative and there's not
human research directly showing that it
increases sleep quantity or Sleep
Quality and in fact there was a pretty
recent study on B12 supplementation in
humans finding like no measurable impact
on sleep so it's it's one of those
things where like speculatively I could
potentially see see it having beneficial
effects in specific circumstances yeah
like in particular if you if you have a
really late chronotype or just if your
circadian rhythm gets up vitamin
B12 might help make kind of that whole
process slightly more sensitive to light
to like help and train a slightly better
circadian rhythm shift that melatonin
ramp up a little bit earlier which might
help you go to bed a little bit earlier
um but again like that this is like very
speculative and that's kind of the only
situation where I could see it directly
potentially even having a direct impact
apart from like quote unquote supporting
natural melatonin production yeah
so to kind of wrap up some of these
supplement questions
um there are a couple other popular
supplements that the other products
mentioned so nightfood mentioned
tryptophan and magnesium we haven't
talked about those yet
um I've definitely seen those
recommended before as relatively popular
sleep supplements and tryptophan is the
thing that people always bring up on
Thanksgiving saying that like oh turkey
has tryptophan it's going to make you
sleepy I know that's mostly been
debunked at this point but I still when
I when I see the word tryptophan I think
of turkey
both tryptophan and magnesium are listed
as unproven supplements on examines
sleep supplements page
um but Greg do you want to talk at all
about either of those sure yeah yeah so
there's a lot to get into with
tryptophan
um and I'll talk about it a little bit
more later when I discuss
macronutrients in particular oh cool but
the the big reason people are so
interested in tryptophan is that
tryptophan is kind of the the basis for
melatonin production so your body starts
with tryptophan does some to it
like multiple chemical reactions occur
get different little functional groups
put on it and eventually it becomes
melatonin so uh tryptophan levels in in
your blood and tryptophan intake are
certainly important for melatonin
production
um in much the same way that like uh
cholesterol the molecule is necessary
for steroid hormone synthesis like it's
it's a similar type of deal
um and tryptophan is is definitely
important for that reason so in research
that experimentally depletes uh
tryptophan levels in in the blood people
do produce way less melatonin and sleep
way less
um like if if they're fed a diet that is
otherwise nutritionally adequate but
just has like no or very very little
tryptophan like that is something that
is observed
um and there is some research on some
like kind of promising research on on
tryptophan uh like supplementation and
sleep there was a 2022
um
meta-analysis and meta regression on
this
finding one there's not a ton of
research on this like there were only
four articles uh included in this meta
and it didn't find significant effects
um
like there have there haven't been
consistent findings of significant
effects on like total sleep time or
Total Sleep Quality or time spent and
slow wave sleep or rem or like most of
the stuff that people might be
interested in when it comes to sleep
um but this meta-analysis did find that
it might have an effect on uh wake after
sleep onset or if you read a lot of
sleep studies lasso which I think is a
fun acronym
um so yeah like a potentially suggesting
that if you're someone who wakes up
frequently throughout the night and
maybe lays in bed a long time and
struggles to get back to sleep after you
wake up during the night
ah like maybe tryptophan might do a
little bit a little bit of something for
you but
um
yeah not as much as I think a lot of
people expect like I think I think a lot
of people look at it
more mechanically than biology tends to
function where they they just think like
oh tryptophan is the thing that becomes
melatonin so if I eat more tryptophan or
supplement with tryptophan I will make
more melatonin and melatonin causes me
to sleep therefore I will sleep more and
that's good yeah
um but yeah that's not how like
biological regulation works if you
already consume adequate amounts of
tryptophan putting more in there
probably isn't going to necessarily
increase melatonin production and just
more and more melatonin won't
necessarily help you sleep more or
better yeah um because there's a lot of
other stuff going on with sleep so yeah
tryptophan
I hmm
I think I think examine might be being
slightly too conservative by calling it
unproven because like there there is
again like a mechanistic reason to
suspect that it might be beneficial
especially for people who might have low
tryptophan intake and then even for
people who
who we assume are consuming adequate
amounts of tryptophan it probably does
or the the current evidence suggests
that it might decrease wake time after
sleep onset to some extent uh but yeah
you probably shouldn't expect the world
from it yeah are most people consuming
enough tryptophan
um yeah yeah yeah I mean
it's uh oh man I'm going from memory
here but I I think I know this
um so tryptophan I believe is an
essential amino acid
um like it's it's not one that your body
can just synthesize on its own so like
you do have to get it from your diet
um
but it's
so like if you are a vegetarian or
omnivore
um animal products have plenty of
tryptophan in them yeah you're you're
not going to be eating too little
tryptophan assuming you're eating enough
protein and not like not even
bodybuilder levels of protein just like
RDA of protein yeah
um and then for vegans the
the the two most common amino acid
deficiencies if if there will be ones to
exist are lysine and methionine
um so I I believe that even with a vegan
diet which does have an elevated risk of
maybe being uh like deficient in some of
the essential amino acids uh tryptophan
isn't high on the list of concern there
so
yeah I don't I don't think that's that
much of a concern for most people unless
just total protein intake is very low
yeah yeah
uh okay and then in the case of
magnesium
um
there is some the the observational
research is promising but the direct
experimental research is considerably
less promising so this is a direct quote
from a 2023 review titled the role of
magnesium and sleep Health a systematic
review of available literature
um so here's the quote
observational studies suggested an
association between magnesium statuses
and Sleep Quality while the rcts
reported contradictory findings this
systematic review revealed an
association between magnesium status and
Sleep Quality parentheses daytime
falling asleep sleepiness snoring and
sleep duration close parentheses
according to the observational studies
while the randomized clinical trials
showed an uncertain association between
magnesium supplementation and sleep
disorder the association between dietary
magnesium and sleep patterns needs
well-designed randomized clinical trials
with a larger sample size and longer
follow-up time parentheses more than 12
weeks to further clarify the
relationship so basically
um you know similar to zinc the the
cross-sectional research suggests that
magnesium is pretty important like
um people who who sleep well just tend
to have higher blood magnesium levels
than people who sleep poorly
um but there there haven't been a ton of
uh like actual studies
um like rcts and whatnot looking at the
effects of magnesium supplementation on
sleep quantity and quality and the stuff
that does exist out there is
uh like kind of meh yeah like some
studies find positive effects that are
that tend to be pretty small
um some studies don't and yeah overall
the experimental research is not that
promising uh but there might be a little
bit of something there so uh there was
another uh another meta-analysis
published in 2021
specifically on older adults with
insomnia
um so not a huge body of literature but
there were three studies there
um and they found that in that specific
population magnesium supplementation uh
decreased sleep onset latency which is
basically like how long it takes you to
fall asleep once you get in bed yeah
um decrease sleep onset latency by an
average of about 17 minutes which in uh
improved Total Sleep Time by about 16
minutes
so I don't know like if
if you have insomnia like I I assume an
extra 15 minutes of sleep like you're
probably not gonna be mad about it but
yeah it's probably also not going to be
life-changing yeah I wouldn't think
um and additionally all of the trials
included in that meta-analysis were
great at this having a moderate to high
risk of bias and the outcomes were
supported by a low to very low quality
of evidence so that's
that's basically where things stand on
magnesium like it's uh
I don't know it's it's plausible that 10
years from now there will be a lot more
research and we can estimate effects
more precisely
but it's in in you know maybe it does
actually do something but it's also one
of those things where with the studies
that currently exist if the effect the
theoretical effect that might exist if
it is not yet detectable that does
suggest that it's probably a very small
and inconsistent effect so yeah yeah
interesting I feel like I mean I see so
many people
recommending magnesium and like I know a
lot of people who have tried it for
sleep I've tried it for sleep I think
you have too Greg
um it feels like one of the really
popular
sleep supplements so that's interesting
to hear what the research actually says
yeah I I think it's
[Music]
um
I think it's one of those things where
uh
I don't know I I should I didn't I
didn't look into this in my research for
the podcast I'm just I'm going from
memory and memory could be faulty
um I think magnesium might be kind of
similar to what I said about lavender
where
I I think there is some research that
magnesium supplementation might help
might help with like perceived Stress
and Anxiety a little bit yeah
um particularly for people who might
have elevated levels of Stress and
Anxiety so it could it could be that for
that specific population magnesium
itself isn't directly improving sleep
but it might help kind of bring you down
enough that the the other things that
would generally be promoting sleep can
do what they're supposed to do to
actually help you get to sleep
um see like I I could see that being the
case with magnesium but for
to this point it doesn't seem like just
supplementing with magnesium
indiscriminately for everyone has a
particularly large or reliable effect on
improving sleep right
um yeah so the next thing is the the
things in the Sleepy chocolate yes yeah
so that's Valerian and melatonin yes uh
Valerian is listed as an unproven
supplement on examinants guide again and
melatonin is one of the two listed as a
secondary supplement along with lavender
as we've already talked about so for
Valerian
um the examine page said the available
randomized controlled trials examining
the effectiveness of valerian for
improving sleep have produced mostly
mixed results
yeah I I think that that's a pretty fair
assessment
um Valerian is one where there's really
promising in vitro research so much like
chamomile there's a there's some
bioactive molecules in Valerian that do
seem to enhance Gaba signaling which is
generally inhibitory helps bring you
down associated with good sleep blah
blah blah All Good Things
um but yeah the human research like
actually giving Valerian to people and
looking at effects on sleep isn't
particularly positive yeah and one of
the reasons for that is there are
questions about whether the bioactive
compounds that might by themselves
improve sleep related signaling there
are questions about whether they
actually survive oral supplementation
which is a problem with some supplements
and compounds in general like you know
do they just get completely
destroyed by the hydro chloric acid in
your stomach or the slight basic
environment in your small intestine or
just like any of your digestive enzymes
and does enough of them like do enough
of the molecules actually you know make
it into your bloodstream right to have
their purported effects and in the case
of valerian that's that that seems
somewhat doubtful so it's like and I'm
certainly not recommending this
absolutely not but just like
theoretically to to illustrate the point
I'm making if you could like if you got
an IV drip of some of those compounds in
Valerian
um maybe they would have a beneficial
effect on sleep because you're bypassing
digestion just getting them right into
your bloodstream
um I'm not saying that they would but
I'm saying that that would be
possible
um but yeah it seems somewhat doubtful
that when you actually swallow them and
eat them
um that much if any of those potentially
beneficial compounds for Sleep actually
get into your bloodstream yeah what a
bummer yeah and then for melatonin
um
yeah I mean it is
it pretty clearly works like it is one
of the only sleep supplements that the
the the general consensus both of
experts in the field and the data itself
like like melatonin does what it's
supposed to do like it does help you
sleep better yeah
um but like the examine page pointed out
the effects are pretty modest
um and they're primarily seen in people
who either have Sleep Disorders or
several risk factors for Sleep Disorders
so if you're already a pretty decent
sleeper and you supplement with
melatonin
um you you potentially could still
expect a small decrease in sleep onset
latency and maybe a small Improvement in
Sleep Quality but it's probably not
going to make a night and day difference
like I think
I think with with a lot of supplements
people come into them with
dramatically excessive expectations yeah
and I think that's especially true for
melatonin yeah people think it's like a
pharmaceutical well it is in Europe oh
fair enough
um yeah so
there are a few things going on like
melatonin is a hormone and I think
people for for understandable reasons
um the the they they know what hormones
are on a rough conceptual level and they
have this idea that like ah if my
hormones are out of whack or something's
too high or too low like that's going to
have really big physiological changes
um and and that certainly can be true
for certain hormones uh
but you know not not all hormones are
created equal
um and like in the case of melatonin
like it's
it's not like that strong of a hormone
yes
um and also it doesn't exclusively just
do sleep related stuff melatonin is also
kind of a general purpose antioxidant
um like we're going to talk about this a
little bit later in the episode but
um like a lot of plants have some levels
of melatonin in them and I think that
confuses some people because it's like
plants don't need to sleep what's going
on here it's like it's silly plants they
don't need to sleep yeah but but
melatonin
um is is a pretty conserved compound
like it does in like I'm using that in
the evolutionary sense like a lot of
different branches of the Tree of Life
produce melatonin and it probably
initially started being produced like
hundreds of millions if not billions of
years ago long long time ago nice
um because it is like a very effective
General antioxidant
um
and the current theory is that it
initially kind of evolved and became a
thing that probably single-celled
organisms started producing to help
protect against oxidative damage from
like uh reactive oxygen species
formation from mitochondria
um do what Powerhouse of the cell yeah
absolutely so yeah like like melatonin
does certainly have effects on like
brain neurochemistry and is a hormone
that is uh that affects sleep and can
improve sleep especially if you don't if
your pineal gland isn't producing enough
melatonin on its own like those are all
true but yeah like not not all hormones
are like blasting gear or and they they
won't all have the magnitude of effects
that women experience when they go
through menopause like and in the case
of melatonin like it's it's it's a
hormone but it's you know like take
taking a melatonin pill is not the same
thing as like pinning two grams of trend
and I there's a lot of confusion about
that no like I I don't think anyone like
explicitly believes that yeah I know but
I think a lot of people have in their
mind like oh melatonin hormone hormone
powerful scary whatever right
um and since it's powerful it will
therefore knock me out yeah as
if it's Ambien exactly
um and it doesn't no so yeah like it it
helps but but if if you take it don't
don't expect the world
all right
gets us through the specific supplements
that were mentioned in
those products that we talked about
um
I guess I'll just say to end this
section
um if you want to try any of these or
other sleep supplements
um we'd recommend you check out examine
sleep supplement guide for more
information obviously I've referenced it
like a thousand times already but very
good resource
um overall though I obviously don't
think it's efficient both in terms of
dose and the monetary cost to get your
sleep related vitamins minerals and
supplements from these products like
from the cereal from the chocolate from
the cookies and ice cream
um so now we're going to move into what
the science actually says about
nutrition and sleep and like some
specific recommendations that we have
um
we'll start with snacks since the kind
of premise of this of the beginning of
this episode was about like ooh eating
cereal as your little pre-bed snack so
if you'd like to have a snack before bed
and want to see if consuming foods that
are naturally rich in magnesium
tryptophan or melatonin work for you I
found some examples of items on
sleepfoundation.org that are rich in
some of these micronutrients so a banana
with almond butter will get you some
magnesium oatmeal would get you some
magnesium and melatonin pistachios
melatonin and tryptophan and yogurt for
calcium protein vitamins b6 and b12 and
magnesium I also reread an article by
Eric Trexler published in Volume 5 of
mass where he recommends trying tart
cherry juice and kiwi fruit as pre-bed
snacks as well tart cherry juice
contains melatonin and increases the bio
activity of tryptophan and kiwi is
thought to enhance sleep due to its
serotonin and folate content
I I just wanted to note I am
slightly uh skeptical about uh claims
related to melatonin in food directly
affecting sleep
um so yeah like I mentioned before lots
of plants produce a little bit of
melatonin primarily to serve as an
antioxidant
um
and the
there there's again kind of like
cross-sectional research looking at
associations between uh food intake of
foods rich in melatonin and sleep
quantity and quality that does tend to
be pretty positive but that is also
potentially confounded because
most most of the foods that are going to
be rich in melatonin are just like
associated with generally good diet
quality and generally good health like
it's it's mostly like fruits and
vegetables so it could simply be that
people who eat a generally healthy diet
are generally healthier and generally
engage in more behaviors that
um might uh more directly influence
Sleep Quality and the Melatonin content
of the foods they consume is just kind
of a latent construct almost that's like
associated with all of those other good
things yeah not actually causal
um
and I found a very interesting review
from this past year that I'm going to
talk about quite a bit more later when I
talk about carbohydrates
um that was that that also addressed
this issue like the the Melatonin
content of foods and whether or not that
was likely to actually influence sleep
and so the thing is there is melatonin
in some food products but most of those
food products
don't actually have much melatonin in
them
um so you know we're talking like I
don't know five micrograms or some
like that yeah and so you know this guy
basically makes the case that yeah like
it's this is something that's true but
also probably not useful like there is
melatonin in Foods if you eat more of
these Foods you will be consuming more
melatonin but it's pretty unlikely that
you would end up consuming enough
melatonin to actually move the needle on
sleep yeah that makes sense tart tart
cherries are
potentially the one exception of that
because among plants that do produce
melatonin it does have like particularly
high levels but you would still need to
eat a shitload of tart cherries to
consume enough melatonin but but tart
cherry juice might might potentially
have enough melatonin to actually have
an effect but I'm
I am somewhat skeptical about like the
oatmeal or yeah like milk has a little
melatonin in it like I'm I'm skeptical
about that
um
for kiwi specifically
so in in the mass article you referenced
uh kiwi was recommended due to its
serotonin and folate content and the
thing with serotonin is that is part of
the the pathway of melatonin synthesis
like you start with tryptophan you get
some other things and then you get
serotonin and then the serotonin is
converted to melatonin
um so yeah like like kiwi does have some
serotonin in it and there is actually
not a ton of human evidence looking at
the effects of kiwi on sleep but there
are three studies and they're all like
quite positive
um including one in athletes and and
that will all be linked in the show
notes uh like everything else will so
um yeah it does seem like consuming kiwi
and that includes fresh kiwi some of
these studies used uh like dried kiwi
some use kiwi juice and it all it all
seemed to be pretty good
um but I'm I I am somewhat skeptical
that it's due to the folate and
serotonin content I think it's more
likely to be due to apogen and much like
chamomile
um like that is the the bioactive
compound in chamomile that is most
likely to influence sleep uh interacts
with the benzodiazepine receptor
influence Gap influences Gaba related
signaling so uh kiwi also has relatively
high concentrations of apogen in it and
so yeah like it does seem like you
eating kiwi before bed improves sleep
and I yeah it could be the serotonin
could be the folate I suspect it's more
so due to the epigenan though yep
thank you
yeah so now we've talked about
specifically like pre-bed snacks and I
think Greg you have some stuff about
just overall diet and how your nutrition
can impact sleep I do I do so
let me start by giving a bit of an
introduction for the kind of purported
mechanistic pathway that a lot of claims
related to uh like macronutrient intake
and sleep tend to follow
and most of that is due to
um
like like tryptophan related metabolism
so okay essentially here's what's going
on okay
you have Transporters
that allow things to cross your
blood-brain barrier like like most
things in your blood don't make it into
your brain but certain things can they
have to cross the barrier and there are
specific Transporters for the stuff that
can make it into your brain and there
there's like some like little things
that can kind of squeak through but most
of the time like larger things like
amino acids or whatever need to be
transported via one of these
Transporters and there is a single
transporter for all large neutral amino
acids which includes tryptophan but also
includes
um a lot of other amino acids like I
don't remember all of them right off the
top of my head but I know that like
histidine leucine isoleucine valine a
couple others are
in the category of large neutral amino
acids and so
there is this idea that if you consume
carbohydrate and in particular like high
glycemic carbohydrate like sugar white
bread something along those lines before
bed that will improve sleep by
increasing tryptophan uptake in the
brain because essentially all of the
large neutral amino acids are competing
for for that single transporter and a
lot of these amino acids you have higher
levels in your bloodstream than you do
for tryptophan so less tryptophan is
getting into your brain relative to some
of these other large neutral amino acids
and so
um and a lot of these large neutral
amino acids are amino acids that are
present in relatively High quantities
and concentrations in muscle tissue and
are and they're uptake into muscle
tissue is sensitive to insulin so the
idea is you eat carbohydrate
particularly high glycemic carbohydrate
soon before bed that will increase
insulin release and increase amino acid
uptake into the muscle and preferably
and preferentially a lot of those other
large neutral amino acids will be taken
up by the muscle leaving relatively
higher concentrations of tryptophan
relative to those other amino acids in
your blood therefore more tryptophan
molecules will make it through the large
neutral amino acid transporter crossing
the blood-brain barrier getting into the
brain and then being available for
melatonin synthesis that is
that is basically the story that is told
yeah
um
and it's like like a lot of other things
in this episode both completely true and
also typically completely irrelevant
yeah um so
essentially
that does
that does apply if
it's been a long long time since her
last meal containing protein and if you
don't consume any protein in your final
meal before bed like it is just
carbohydrate
um there there is evidence suggesting
that that will like marginally increase
tryptophan uptake into the brain there's
not good evidence suggesting that that
does actually increase sleep but kind of
that mechanistic pathway is is partially
supported
but there are
implications of that that aren't
supported by the general evidence so one
of one of the issues with this is that
there has been other research that has
been done looking to see basically how
much protein would you need to consume
with the carbohydrate in order for it to
uh like basically to completely get rid
of the effect because you know you eat
protein you're also consuming more large
neutral amino acids that will then be in
higher concentrations in your blood etc
etc and it seems like if the total
protein content of that final
carbohydrate containing meal exceeds
like five percent of total calories The
increased uptake in tryptophan in the
brain completely goes away
and so uh an implication of that is just
that like
consuming protein before bed should
up your sleep because it's it would then
be putting more amino acids into your
bloodstream that would be competing with
with tryptophan
um but protein overall seems to have
like a neutral to positive effect on
sleep so anyway like a lot of claims
related to macronutrient distribution
and sleep relate to that okay that
purported like mechanistic uh pathway
but the the review that I mentioned
earlier that talked about the Melatonin
content of food like it it talks about
this in considerably more depth and
discusses like why it is uh like almost
never particularly relevant
um so yeah that'll be linked in the show
notes uh so yeah like moving on from
that now that now that that background
has been established
um
let's first
talk by or just talk about kind of like
all of the macronutrients together does
does your macronutrient distribution
like your ratio of proteins to carbs to
Fat Etc
um influence sleep and the research
suggests uh probably not all that much
so there was a 2020 meta-analysis and
here's just a brief quote from it a
total of 19 relevant articles were
selected and it was observed that good
sleepers which they operationally
defined as sleeping greater than or
equal to seven hours per night with a
global sleep score uh less than or equal
to five sleep latency under 30 minutes
sleep efficiency above 85 percent like
that was their operational definition
so good sleepers had a slightly higher
energy distribution from dietary protein
than poor sleepers on the other hand
good sleepers showed a relatively lower
percentage of energy from dietary
carbohydrate and fat than poor sleepers
however meta regression analysis
revealed no dose dependent association
between the macronutrient distributions
and sleep duration these results suggest
that consuming a greater proportion of
dietary protein May benefit may have
benefits on improving Sleep Quality in
healthy adults however findings may be
susceptible to reverse causality so
where does that leave us okay so yeah
let's let's break this down a little bit
so essentially what they found is that
good sleepers consumed a little bit more
protein and a little bit less fat and
carbohydrate than people who didn't meet
those criteria for being good sleepers
but uh there wasn't a dose response
relationship observed which if higher
protein intakes were mechanistically
like causing sleep to improve you would
expect some type of dose response
relationship may not may not be linear
it could be that you know you see
gradual improvements till protein gets
up to like 30 percent of calories and
then levels off or or whatever but yeah
you should expect some sort of
discernible dose response relationship
but they didn't see that
um which suggests
kind of like I was talking about before
it could be that a macronutri a
macronutrient distribution within a
certain realm is just associated with
other health promoting sleep promoting
activities so people who are more
interested in like Fitness and their
health and whatnot are probably the
people who are eating slightly higher
levels of protein and also sleeping
somewhat better
um so I I kind of suspect that's what's
going on uh but it does it does at least
throw water on the idea that protein
intake would have a negative effect on
Sleep Quality or if it or if it does
like it wasn't detectable in this data
um so yeah like like protein I I
personally don't think that like trying
to get super high levels of protein
intake will actually improve your sleep
but this meta does suggest that in my
opinion I think it mostly suggests that
protein has a neutral effect on skin
yeah but it it kind of in the realm of
neutral to slightly positive okay uh
moving on to sugar and carbohydrates I
wanted to talk about sugar first like we
we wanted to talk about the effect of
sugar intake on sleep a little bit more
uh because you're talking about cereal
chocolate cookies yeah Etc
um and I was like you know sugar is
something that the medical establishment
is currently quite concerned about like
high levels of sugar intake high levels
of added sugar intake people eating
marshmallows for breakfast people eating
marshmallows for breakfast and there's
also a lot of concern and research
attention on sleep because people do
seem to be sleeping less than before
Sleep Quality doesn't seem to be as good
as it used to be so you would think that
there would be a lot of research at that
intersection looking at the effect of
sugar on sleep yeah
there was surprisingly little and a lot
of the stuff that did exist
um was stuff just looking at
associations and
it was it was based on like larger data
sets that are collected for different
purposes where you know you're
collecting a ton of data about people
but you also include like food recalls
surveys or food frequency questionnaires
that ask about the frequency of
consumption of various products that are
high in sugar or are sugar sweetened and
so that's where most of the evidence
comes from and uh it was it was kind of
funny like this uh there was a 2023 meta
on the topic that will be linked in the
show notes but basically it found that
like
in kids just like total higher sugar
consumption was associated with worse
sleep
um but the thing about sugar consumption
is a lot of people get most of their
sugar from sugar sweetened Beverages and
in particular sodas yeah and sodas also
have most of them also have caffeine in
them so yeah that affects sleep in kids
they found a a significant negative
effect of total sugar intake on sleep
but they found a even higher negative
effect of soda intake on sleep which
makes sense now we're getting into the
realm of is this the sugar is it the
yeah is it the caffeine right and then
furthermore what is another class of
sugar sweetened beverages where intake
is currently on the rise uh in America
and also like worldwide you guessed it
energy drinks which were
included in kind of the total sugar
consumption and sugar sweetened beverage
intake uh but yeah what do you know
increased consumption of energy drinks
was also associated with with worse
sleep but breaking news yeah that's
that's in that's a no type of
finding
um
data on data on adults
um there there was less research on
adults in general like there a lot of
the concern with this is like sugar
intake in kids because kids
eat way more sugar than adults less
restraint Etc right
um but yeah the in adults like soda
intake was also
um associated with like a 20
uh higher rate of getting uh less than
sufficient sleep and uh consuming more
energy drinks was associated with a 58
increase oh no insufficient sleep but
again it like it's it's hard to chalk
that up to Sugar yeah
but yeah so I don't know the like I I
kind of suspect that consuming a ton of
sugar before bed probably isn't ideal
for sleep but the research on that is is
less than you would expect it to be yeah
um
let's see so there was a 2021
meta-analysis moving beyond sugar just
talking about carbohydrate uh more
generally there was a 2021 uh systematic
review and meta-analysis that I believe
was reviewed in Mass back in the day
um but yeah it was looking at
um like carbohydrate like total
carbohydrate intake and also uh like
glycemic index of the carbohydrate being
consumed and its effects on like really
everything associated with sleep so
quantity quality wait time after sleep
onset sleep latency time spent in each
sleep stage etc etc
and uh it found that low carb intake
high carbon take low glycemic carbon
take high glycemic carb intake
uh didn't really seem to be associated
with like major differences in Total
Sleep Time Total Sleep efficiency
um all of that stuff but they did find
that lower carbohydrate intake was
associated with more uh like slow wave
sleep and higher carb intake was
associated with more REM sleep
and uh similar with um so high glycemic
index carbs were associated with
slightly higher sleep efficiency while
low GI carbs were associated with
slightly improved sleep onset latency no
social one do you do it's it's kind of a
queen you can't do both yeah it's it's
tough it's tough
um
yeah it's and also like the the effect
sizes there we're all like pretty yeah
pretty moderate that makes sense in
terms of like the the they used uh
effect sizes in the Cohen's D family and
the differences they found were kind of
in the 0.3 to 0.4 range if memory serves
which are yeah like modest effect sizes
um so yeah like it's it's hard to know
what to do with that like you know I
generally slow wave sleep and REM
sleeper that are the two like most
important sleep stages like that's how
it's generally conceived of yeah uh yeah
low carb is good for one high carb is
better for the other uh you you probably
won't good sleep efficiency but you also
want to fall asleep quickly when you go
to bed and like high GI is good for one
low GI is good for the other and again
like we're talking uh more associations
here so
yeah like it's it's kind of a wash uh
like this adds to the discussion that
maybe total carbohydrate intake and
glycemic index could be affecting sleep
in some way but it's hard to directly
say if the impact is positive or
negative or if it's just doing different
things you know right uh moving on
there was
um
there was a 2022 narrative review
looking at the effects of dietary
carbohydrate profiles on uh nocturnal
metabolism sleep and general well-being
and uh I mostly just wanted to mention
this and Link it in the show notes
because it brings up an interesting
possibility that glycemic regulation
might be playing a role in all of this
and and might partially explain why high
and low GI carbs might have
slightly different effects overall and
maybe even different effects for
different people
so there is quite a bit of research
showing that poor glycemic control is
associated with worse Sleep Quality and
maybe even like causative of worse Sleep
Quality
and one of the potential explanations
there is that uh like poor glycemic
control could influence other hormones
that relate to glucose availability but
also could have negative impacts on
sleep
so if your blood sugar gets too low or
if you are like pre-diabetic or whatever
and so your body can't use the glucose
that's already in your blood
particularly well something that can
happen is is your body will be like oh
hey like we we need more glucose in our
blood to you know provide fuel for the
stuff that needs it
um so two of the hormones that your body
might release to increase glucose
availability like cause your body to
break down more glycogen release it into
the bloodstream are cortisol and
norepinephrine which both have generally
negative impacts on sleep yeah they tend
to promote like wakefulness
and so
it could be that a lot of the stuff
related to total carbohydrate intake or
carb quality or GI might generally be
more relevant for people with worse
blood glucose control so for a lot of
people it just doesn't seem to matter
because your your body your pancreas
like handles all of that pretty well but
for for people who might be kind of
walking down the road to pre-diabetes or
type 2 diabetes
um it could be that for them because
their glycemic control is worse
um the carbohydrate quantity in quality
might become more relevant for them due
to the effects of stuff like cortisol
and norepinephrine trying to like
maintain glucose availability throughout
the night
um and then going back to the 2022
narrative review that I mentioned
previously when uh talking about both
melatonin content of foods and also
um
uh oh the the tryptophan and
carbohydrate and Insulin related pathway
large neutral amino acid transporter so
I've I've brought this up twice already
and I would highly recommend you read
this like this was I think my favorite
paper I read when preparing for this
episode because it's um
I don't know it's
it it has the vibe of
someone who is just intensely frustrated
with his entire field uh iconic which is
which is fun because like a lot of this
just comes down to like hey a lot of
people are making claims that that and
this is kind of a theme in this episode
are like technically true but probably
not relevant to most of the we're
studying like yeah like you talk about
melatonin and foods and like yeah it's
there but probably not enough to
actually matter you talk about this this
mechanism related to insulin causing uh
BCAA disposal and that allowing greater
tryptophan uptake into the brain and
melatonin synthesis and like yeah that's
true but like if people are consuming
any protein like it it becomes
irrelevant like come on like what the
are you talking about so it's it's
it's a guy who's like grinding and acts
in a very professional way
um while also cutting through a lot of
what he perceives to be as the
in his field so it's it's a it's a
really fun paper I think
um but the the case that that the
authors of this paper make
is that
um and this this kind of Builds on what
I was talking about before with the
glycemic control glucose regulation he
he basically makes the case that
um the effects of carbohydrate on sleep
are primarily like regulated or
modulated by brain energy status
um and I'll I will readily admit here
that some of the neurophysiology he
discusses in this paper goes over my
head like like I talked about on the
aspartame episode I'm not a rodent
physiology guy I am also not a
neurophysiology guy like I I know I have
plenty of uh of blind spots there
um but yeah he seems to be making a
similar case to what I was discussing
with the prior study with like the
cortisol norepinephrine energy status
whatever
um so basically the case being laid out
is that
um like certain neurons that promote
sleep need to have adequate glucose
Supply to like do what they need to do
to like ramp up neurochemical Pathways
to actually promote sleep and
restfulness
um but that if like if if energy levels
and energy availability is too high that
will just
further ramp up the activity of just
every other part of the brain kind of
which most of your brain isn't used to
sleep yeah so it's like it's like a
little bit of a balancing act I guess
um
and and this would also in part like
partially explain some of the stuff I
talked about before related to total
carbohydrate intake and quality and like
sleep architecture
um so like the your brain uses a lot
more energy during REM sleep than the
other sleep stages because like you're
it's using an amount of energy that's
like comparable to to being awake even
whereas like during other stages of
sleep and specifically slow wave sleep
brain energy usage is way way lower yeah
um so you know this would essentially
explain why like maybe higher
carbohydrate intake might be beneficial
for REM sleep because your your brain
just has more energy to do all of the
stuff it does in in REM sleep whereas
like if uh if like glucose availability
and energy availability is too high it
might be too stimulatory just on a
purely bioenergetic level right to
settle into a bunch of slow wave sleep
um
anyway yeah it was it was an interesting
paper like he he contends that
um
yet total carbohydrate intake and
carbohydrate quality do do probably
affect
Total Sleep Time and sleep architecture
to some extent but it might be due more
so to energy status rather than that
kind of like tryptophan melatonin
synthesis related pathway uh but yeah
really cool paper
and that's all I have to say about
carbohydrate do you have any questions
or comments about that before we before
we move on I don't think so I'd like to
know about protein okay perfect uh so
protein
as I mentioned before that 2020
meta-analysis just looking at just
general macronutrient ratios tended to
find a generally like positive
associations with higher protein intake
but you know again hard to separate
correlation from causation there was
also a 2023
meta-analysis its purpose was to examine
the effects of increased protein intake
which they defined as at least one gram
per kilo per day or at least 25 percent
of total energy intake or
supplementation of at least 10 grams of
protein per day on sleep outcomes in
adults so here is a direct quote from
that paper 12 intervention studies
reported on in 10 articles were included
the qualitative analyzes showed that
increased protein consumption has little
influence on sleep outcomes only
subjective Sleep Quality was positively
associated with protein consumption in a
few studies meta-analyzes also showed no
significant effect of increased protein
intake on sleep outcomes
with very low certainty of evidence
however results from sensitivity
analyzes excluding high risk studies
suggests a small effect on Sleep Quality
in favor of higher protein intake so
yeah I mean that's that's about what we
got so kind of that that comports pretty
well with what I was saying about the
study on the the macronutrient ratios
like you you do maybe see slightly
better sleep in people consuming more
protein but in studies that are like
experimentally testing it it doesn't
seem like increased protein intake
really has a positive or negative effect
on sleep like it might it might have a
small effect on subjective Sleep Quality
but it's it's probably just not all that
important
um and and don't take that too far like
it it is important like if you're
consuming no protein whatsoever yeah
you're consuming no tryptophan your
sleep's gonna it's gonna be a lot of
stuff wrong yeah not just your sleep but
within kind of the range of protein
intakes that most humans consume
it just doesn't seem like it is either
that strongly associated with sleep
outcomes or like causative of different
sleep outcomes mm-hmm
um moving on uh so so most of the
research looking at the the effects of
macronutrients on sleep have focused on
carbohydrate and protein
there's a little bit on fat worth
bringing up
um so there's there's some research on
the effect of Omega
Omega-3s on sleep
um and some effects have been observed
in infants and children but not so much
in adults although there haven't there
hasn't been a ton of research on that
um there is one study suggesting that
maybe higher levels of saturated fat
intake might be somewhat bad for Sleep
um when the study was published I saw a
lot of people talking about it and
catastrophizing about it a little bit
like it does
it does suggest that saturated fat is
bad but it's all it is also just one
study and
uh due to how much
concern people have about sleep and how
much concern there is in the nutritional
establishment about saturated fat intake
and the fact that both of those things
are Quantified and a lot of really big
data sets I do kind of think that if
there were strong associations yeah
unsaturated fat intake and sleep it
would be like pretty strongly known so
uh take this with a grain of salt but
there was a study from I think I think
maybe like
2016. like it's yeah yeah 2016. so like
recent ish but now seven years ago but I
remember when this was published
um and and people like freaked out about
it a little bit but
um the the way this study worked is
there were three days of controlled
feeding followed by one day of AD
libidum feeding so like basically people
ate a prescribed controlled diet for
three days and then one day they just
ate whatever they wanted
um
and the researchers observed Baseline
sleep architecture in response to the
control diet and then they observed how
it changed during the day when people
just consumed what they wanted to
and they found that higher fiber intake
was associated with uh more slow wave
sleep and higher saturated fat intake
was associated with less slow wave sleep
so you know it's I think it's somewhat
hard to know what to do with that
because you know it
once again like correlation versus
causation this this is like a
semi-experimental design but it wasn't
like an RCT so it can't necessarily
establish causation
and you know it it could just be that
again folks who are generally
healthier and more concerned about that
stuff and you know maybe just typically
have healthier eating patterns and
healthier lifestyles in general were the
ones when they're like oh I'm back in
control of my diet I'm going to eat more
fiber rich foods yeah and then the
people who like maybe don't care quite
as much about their health and yeah you
know the the basically the saturated fat
intake is just like a correlate for a
lot a lot of other like lifestyle
factors and other that could be
influencing yeah see I I went in
I wouldn't uh put too many eggs in that
basket but there there is at least some
suggestion that high intakes of
saturated fat might negatively affect uh
slow wave sleep
um
and then finally I guess just kind of to
wrap up uh this section there was a 2021
paper from uh from annual reviews and
it uh
it sums up a lot of the association
studies here and and this will be linked
in the show notes but
basically when you just look at
cross-sectional research everything you
think of is like oh yeah that's a good
diet like high in fruits and vegetables
like whatever like plenty of protein low
saturated fat like yeah basically what
you think of as a healthy diet is also
the diet that is generally like the
dietary patterns that are generally
associated with good sleep
um
and for the fifth time hard to know if
that's causal or mere associations but
um yeah just in total to kind of sum up
this section
the the research on like macronutrients
and diet quality and all of that
generally suggests that like
you probably don't need to do anything
crazy with your diet to promote good
sleep nice
um
like moderate macronutrient
distributions seem to be fine if you eat
but if you eat less carbs and more fat
than that it's also fine you might get a
little more slow wave sleep out of it if
you eat a little more uh uh fat and a
little or a little more carbs a little
less fat you might get a little bit more
Rim sleep out of it but overall sleep
will be pretty fine if you eat more
total protein relative to fat and
carbohydrates maybe it'll improve
subjective Sleep Quality a little bit
Yeah like and probably not that big of a
deal and um
yeah I mean who knows maybe the
Melatonin content of plants is directly
beneficial or like maybe people who live
otherwise help healthy sleep promoting
lives do just tend to eat more fruits
and vegetables but yeah just just like
eating eating a normal diet
seems to be fine for sleep and
um
yeah don't consume too many energy
drinks like that was that was a pretty
strong find yeah yeah
um but yeah like I I I see a lot of
people who are looking for kind of like
Diet hacks to sleep better right and in
my read of the research it it doesn't
really seem like they exist
um
like most most diets can be diets that
are compatible with good sleep but by
the same token if you have bad sleep
there probably aren't
any just like really simple diet there
probably aren't any simple dietary
tweaks that will massively change that
yeah
um
I I could potentially see that being the
case for people with poor blood glucose
regulation for for some of the other uh
for some of the reasons previously
discussed
um but even that's still like somewhat
speculative so
yeah for the most part it it would be
nice if I could say like hey stick to
this particular macronutrient
distribution and your sleep will will be
way better according to the research but
the research just doesn't support any
claims like that unfortunately
but also fortunately for flexibility
because like most yeah most ways you
could want to eat are probably just fine
right for getting good that's good yeah
all right that's all that we prepared
about pre-sleep nutrition but like you
mentioned at the top of the episode we
asked in the communities for people to
send in questions about this topic so
let's go ahead and answer some of those
yeah let's do it let's do it
um so let's start with a question from
Justin Collins
hey Greg here's one for pre-sleep
nutrition so protein before bed is
something that tends to be emphasized a
lot as one last chance to get some extra
muscle protein synthesis going on
and for me I tend to find that if I get
protein too close to bed that I tend to
overheat quite a bit thus losing in
Sleep Quality is there any research on
this
um it's something that I don't see
talked about a lot and I wanted to get
your thoughts and maybe what
your view of the research says about the
loss of Sleep Quality versus that extra
muscle protein synthesis thanks all
right yeah so uh that is that is a good
question and one thing to keep in mind
when when discussing anything related to
human research is that individual
mileage may vary
um so the research looking at pre-sleep
nutrition in aggregate doesn't suggest
that eating protein right before pretty
soon before bed on average decreases
Sleep Quality but
it is also entirely possible that it
decreases Sleep Quality for you so if
that's the case just one thing to note
about the pre-sleep protein literature
is that it does tend to find that if you
consume protein right before you go to
bed
um protein synthesis is obviously higher
overnight and so total like 24 hour
protein synthesis might be higher
um and there's even I believe a
longitudinal study looking at the
effects of like actually giving people
protein before bed uh dirt in a
resistance training context over like
eight to twelve weeks or something like
that finding that it improved uh
hypertrophy outcomes
but one thing to note is that the
longitudinal studies on the topic that
exist
um haven't been matched for total
protein intake
um so basically like say you have a
group consuming 120 grams of protein a
day the other group that is provided
pre-sleep protein might get 40 grams of
protein before sleep so now they're
consuming 160 grams of protein per day
and so it's hard to say whether the
beneficial effects scene are due to the
pre-sleep protein in particular or just
higher total protein in general right
and so
um
one I'm I am not sold on the idea that
pre-sleep protein intake is necessarily
special if you're equating total protein
intake so if you're finding that
consuming protein before bed is
negatively affecting your your sleep
quantity or quality I'd say just consume
that protein at some other point and
it'll probably be fine like I don't I
I'm I I understand why some people think
that that pre-sleep feeding window is a
crucial time for protein intake but I'm
I'm just not I'm just not sold on it
like I I would want to see research
comparing protein matched uh conditions
with maybe like 40 grams before bed
versus 40 grams immediately after waking
up right to see if you you act to see if
you observed different outcomes over
time with that sort of setup versus
a non-matched thing where people are
consuming more protein before bed and
the other group is just consuming less
protein overall
um so yeah if if you're experiencing
that consuming protein before bed is
making you hot making you sleep worse
I'd say just don't do it and consume
that protein at some other point in the
day
All Right Moving On
hi Greg hi Lindsay my name is Tom my
question on pre-sleep nutrition is in
regards to protein intake
I seem to remember some years ago that
there is a lot of talk that you know
during the day uh whey protein was
better to have at that point and during
the night time you know before you go to
bed whatnot casing was a way to go and I
think it was because it tends to be a
slower digestion so you're sleeping and
blah blah blah I also seem to remember
that it was debunked because it doesn't
even really make a whole lot of sense to
begin with
but maybe I'm wrong could you said any
light thank you
yeah absolutely
um so I I can shed some light on that
and uh in fact I did in a research
Spotlight uh back in May which we can
link in the show notes so it was uh
discussing
uh so just as just as some background I
guess
um the kind of like thought or
assumption underpinning that question is
that uh you know you're asleep all night
that's eight hours so you might want to
have elevated amino acids in your blood
for a total longer period of time than
than you might otherwise want to just
because you're you're not going to be
eating anything for the next eight to
ten hours right so uh different proteins
digest and their amino acids are
absorbed at different rates different
speeds and uh the protein used most
often in research is whey protein which
is a very fast digesting protein
and in the in the wild and Wacky World
of proteins casein is also a pretty fast
digesting protein but it's a slower
digesting protein than whey so uh
oftentimes you you will see people
saying like hey before sleep casein is
the one to go with because it's a slower
digesting protein it's going to keep
amino acid levels elevated for a larger
chunk of the night than whey would it's
good that's what you should go with
um and and most of the research looking
at overnight muscle protein synthesis or
some of the longitudinal research
looking at pre-sleep protein intake has
used casein as as the protein being
investigated
um but recently there was a study that
directly compared whey to casein for
overnight muscle protein synthesis and
uh like long story short they had very
similar effects
um essentially the the initial spike in
muscle protein synthesis was a little
bit higher with whey and the
uh curve itself stayed elevated above
Baseline for a little bit longer with
casein and over the course of the entire
night
basically identical yeah so
um
yeah so that's that's where that idea
came from
um and that that is essentially the
debunking uh yeah it it the total amount
of protein and its ability to stimulate
muscle protein synthesis seems to be the
primary factor and with a faster
digesting protein it's just going to
stimulate Pro a little more protein
synthesis early on and a little bit less
later in the night with a slower
digesting protein it's going to
stimulate a little bit less muscle
protein synthesis early on a little bit
more later in the night and by the time
you wake up the same thing has occurred
yeah
um but like I mentioned also in my in my
answer yeah I like how they have built
upon each other yeah I maybe I did that
on purpose I I actually didn't uh if if
I were more organized this is the order
I would have chosen though so I'm I'm
thankful for that little bit of
serendipity
um but yeah yeah I'm also not even sold
that it matters all that much in the
first place uh to have protein at all at
that time right yeah and so let me just
say a little bit more about that because
you know it's it's easy to express
skepticism and just leave that hanging
in the air
so
there are a lot of ideas about the
importance of like protein timing that
are based on like acute muscle protein
synthesis research so you know the idea
that you need to eat protein five or six
times a day or whatever and you need to
consume protein right before you go to
bed a lot of that is based on findings
related to
um like the total protein intake per the
the dose response relationship between
protein intake in a single sitting and
muscle protein synthesis stimulation in
that setting
um where you know after about 40 grams
or so in a single sitting including
after a workout it doesn't really seem
like more stimulates further muscle
protein synthesis and outside of a
training context it seems like like 20
25 grams is probably enough
um so then that makes people say like
well okay there's really no point in
ever consuming more than 40 grams of
protein in a meal
um and then there's there's other
research showing or suggesting that
after you consume uh some protein that
there's a bit of a refractory period
where consuming more protein won't
stimulate further increases in muscle
protein synthesis there's like a three
four hour cool off time essentially
before more protein consumption can
trigger another spike in muscle protein
symptoms yeah I've definitely heard that
before yeah and so then that leads to
the idea of like hey you're trying to
get in
um
you know you're if you're trying to get
in 200 grams of protein per day or
something well you shouldn't go over
more than 40 grams per meal because you
would just be wasting the additional
protein you consumed in that meal and
they need to be spaced out by at least
like four hours between meals and also
like you definitely don't want to be
catabolic for any period of time ever so
like you lose all your gains that way
yeah so you want to put one of those
protein feedings right before bed yeah
and so that it creates this you're
really creating a tight schedule for
yourself every day you are like there's
there's a reason that there's a
stereotype that bodybuilders just live
out of Tupperware yeah
um and and like all of that stuff makes
all the sense in the world if you're
looking at acute muscle protein
synthesis research where it breaks down
is that they're has been like research
looking at time restricted feeding
approaches versus people spacing their
their protein intake more throughout the
day right and if a lot of this was a
major concern you would expect time
restricted feeding to do terribly when
it when it comes to like longitudinal
body composition outcomes because like
if you're trying to get in
uh all of that protein in like uh an
eight hour feeding window or in some of
these studies even a four hour feeding
window
um you're either gonna have to go like
more than the like 25 to 40 grams of
protein per meal or you're gonna have to
have your meals much closer spaced than
like three four hours apart like the the
logistics just don't make sense yeah for
you to be able to design a protein
intake regime that will like check all
of these boxes that you think you need
to check based on muscle protein
synthesis studies
but then what we see is like
in terms of actual muscle growth and
body composition results over eight
weeks 12 weeks whatever
they do just fine like they produce the
same results as any other feeding
pattern
um and so this is something we've talked
about on the podcast before like I think
people do have a tendency to like over
extrapolate
um like muscle protein synthesis
research or I mean it is also possible
that that all of that stuff is actually
true and relevant and does apply
longitudinally but it's just simply the
fact that in terms of stimuli for muscle
growth you the resistance training you
do is so much more important than your
diet not that your diet is irrelevant or
unimportant but like the training
stimulus itself is such a larger driver
that even if like optimizing these
little things about your diet maybe
maybe could theoretically have an effect
that if we had studies with 10 times as
many subjects and ran for 10 times as
long they would detect that significant
effect
um
but yeah in in smaller samples over like
relevant time periods we we just don't
see that which suggests that either
there there's some sort of breakdown in
that logical chain where you can't
necessarily assume that you can
extrapolate out acute muscle protein
synthesis results one to one to
long-term hypertrophy results
or it suggests that if that chain of
logic does apply
um it's it's still the magnitude of the
impact is just so small because it is so
much less important than the resistance
training stimulus itself
um
so yeah that's where that's where a lot
of the ideas related to like needing to
consume protein before sleep come from
it's like this is one more feeding
window where you can work in another 25
to 40 gram dose and not have that
catabolic period overnight but yeah I'm
largely based on like the time
restricted feeding research I I am just
very skeptical that that actually makes
much of any difference in the first
place
all right uh last question
hey y'all this is wael from New Jersey
I'm curious about the relative value of
different macronutrients before sleep
I'm in an overall caloric Surplus and
following a weightlifting routine so my
main objective is building muscle so I
typically try to get some protein in
before I go to bed in the form of a
protein shake but I'm curious about
whether I should be getting more
calories before sleep in general too so
put another way does a gram of fat or
carbohydrates have different benefits if
I have it right before sleep compared to
if I have it earlier in the day are
there any pros or cons to shifting these
calories to right before bed or is it
pretty much a wash thanks for answering
love the pod
uh yeah so
short answer
probably not at least as it relates to
sleep
um in terms of like muscle protein
synthesis and muscle growth and whatnot
like I think my answers to the prior two
questions address that yeah
and then in terms of just kind of other
stuff
um so Danny linen wrote a great article
about Chrono nutrition on Stronger by
science back in the day which we can
link in the show notes
um and it talks about more like the the
metabolic effects of energy consumed at
different times in the day
and so this this probably isn't
something to like really pay that much
mind to or like be that concerned about
but there are several lines of evidence
suggesting that overall in the aggregate
it is probably a little bit better to
consume a little bit more of your total
energy earlier in the day versus late in
the day
um so yeah overall
when it comes to like optimizing
pre-sleep nutrition
I'm of the opinion that there's really
not much to optimize uh like if you want
to have a protein shake before bed I'm
not going to tell you not to like it
might have a positive effect I don't
expect it to have a meaningful effect
but you know if it had if it were to
have an effect I would expect it to be
positive
um but I also
probably wouldn't make a point of
specifically shifting more calories late
in the day to consume right before bed
yeah the the Chrono nutrition literature
um suggests that like it's that's
probably not going to have like a major
deleterious effect compared to consuming
stuff earlier in the day but
um and like if it just matches your
preferences better and you find that
consuming a big meal before bed helps
you sleep better like that's cool like
I'm not going to tell you not to but
just in a vacuum on average knowing
nothing else about you
um I would probably not suggest making a
point of Shifting more calories to
consume right before bed like that it it
probably rather than having a neutral to
positive impact on on health and
outcomes like related to body
composition or performance or anything I
would expect that to have a neutral to
slight negative effect relative to
consuming those calories at some other
time in the day
all right all right
for this week's episode
it does how uh how did you enjoy hosting
this one
first Lindsay episode
it was fine
I think you did great for your your
first episode you hosted I'll tell you
try to reign in your chaos is quite a
task I'm exhausted
um I mean you you have more practice
with it than most people I do I'll tell
you this you did way better than I did
hosting my first fireside chat okay I
think I think you crushed it
well if the audience agrees and they
liked this episode they should like rate
subscribe share it with friends
and until then we'll see you in two
weeks thanks for listening
foreign